[موسيقى]
ما هو رابط للجمال الطبيعي والتنوع
الطبيعي للبلد هو
في الواقع ما نضعه للتو على
خشبة المسرح
على سبيل المثال ، يوجد 80 من براكين الطين في العالم
في أذربيجان ، نضع
خدمة نضع بنية تحتية نقوم بإنشاء
عميل لها  تجربة غامرة هي
نفسها مع التنزه في
جبال القوقاز الرائعة والجميلة نفسها مع
الحكومة التي تراقب الطيور تستثمر الكثير وأيضًا
المستثمرين من القطاع الخاص في ترميم جميع
الأماكن
الأثرية والحمامات والكنائس والمساجد
وأيضًا التقاليد المرتبطة على سبيل المثال
الطباعة الحريرية المصنوعة من النحاس لذلك كل هذه
أم  هو استثمار كبير نرى
الأرقام مقارنة بـ 19 وهو
العام القياسي بحوالي 3.2 مليون
مسافر مع 1.6 مليون مسافر في عام 2022 ،
نرى أن 23 ثانية مستمرة في التعافي
وافترضنا أنه حتى نهاية 24 سيصل
تقريبًا إلى أرقام ما قبل الوباء
كنت على استعداد لبدء رحلة الخطوط الجوية الأذربيجانية
إلى البحرين في الكويت بالإضافة
إلى الشبكة الحالية ، فأنا على اتصال قوي جدًا ،
لذلك نرى أن تقريب
الطبيعة من دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي أيضًا للوافدين الذين
يعيشون هنا مع
منتجعات جبلية رائعة للتزلج يعد أحد
الأصول الرئيسية  ويمكننا أن نجلب إلى هذه
المنطقة
تجارب مسار Beaten Track ،
نحن مقتنعون بأن المسافرين يبحثون عن
وجهات غير مزدحمة
تقدم تجارب تغيير أصلية
وهذه هي العناصر الفريدة في
أذربيجان التي سنستمر في تسليط الضوء عليها
في اليوم التالي.  10 سنوات
والأرجح أطول
شكرا لك